verbal abuse from a computer and the
coolest puzzle game in years I'm in
Portal 2 I started my review of portal 2
so late I mean the PlayStation
apocalypse happened I couldn't play
multiplayer I'd meet the single-player
campaign without multiplayer it's like
half the game but now I beat the entire
game so let's review it so portal 1 came
out and who are we kidding that game was
badass see it about an hour and a half
long but it's still bad ass and now
portal 2 is ISA I heard it was twice as
long as portal 1 I think that's cutting
it a little short it seems a little
longer than twice as long and maybe it
is just twice as long but they do a
really good job at making you feel like
it's longer than that and it's just the
single-player campaign the multiplayer
campaign it's about 2/3 as long as the
single-player campaign all in all you're
getting a pretty good game especially
with this kind of innovation now the
concept of portal is pretty simple
you're a human being being tested by a
robot a robot named Gladys who gives you
all sorts of verbal abuse and it's not
just her there are actually a few voices
in this game without giving any spoilers
away yes spoilers in a puzzle game
figure that [ __ ] out good job for the
team at valve for making it possible to
give away spoilers on a puzzle game but
one of the voices in this game is JK
Simmons hilarious so back to the point
this robot is programmed to test people
with a portal gun you have a portal gun
and you can shoot two portals orange
portal and blue portal go in one come
out the other which is necessary for
solving these puzzles and then let the
testing begin awesome concept right and
there's something cool just messing
around with these portals like shootin
one above you and then below you and
just watching you drop forever
entertainment right there and not only
is portal 2 really innovative and smart
but it's not like impossibly smart there
are a couple puzzles where you just like
this is impossible but generally
speaking you can still solve the puzzles
you don't end up like throwing your
controller through your TV or anything
like that but it's also really hilarious
now I see a lot of movies and I watch a
fair amount of TV you know that portal 2
has the funniest and most clever
dialogue I've seen in anything this year
so do yourself a favor if you have an
Android phone just download the app to
the sound board so the characters in
portal 2 who are welcome in advance
now the single-player campaign really
delves into Aperture Science Aperture
Science being the company that came up
with these tests to do on people like
the Dharma Initiative from lost I found
the story really intriguing in a puzzle
game so you get done with the level and
you're rewarded with this like little
treat of information in the form of
really clever dialogues like win win win
triple win but the multiplayer campaign
I found the puzzles really cool although
the multiplayer doesn't have as much to
do with the story a single player does
so although all the
those are cool multiplayer wins for the
puzzles and single player wins for the
story and dialogue although multiplayer
has cool dialogue too now it's really
interesting that it's a first-person
game involving a gun where you don't
shoot anything yet it's still awesome I
don't know about you but with my
first-person games I like blowing [ __ ]
up
I need that BFG 9000 just to eradicate a
room full of dudes but in Portal it's
okay I just want to feel smart when you
solve some of these puzzles you're like
I don't care what anyone says I am a
genius there are a lot of more difficult
puzzle games out there but they're not
as good as portal 2 so I'm a sucker for
hilarious dialogue I'm a sucker for
smart puzzle games and I'm a sucker for
innovation in Portal 2 has all three
there's not a single level in the game
where you like that wasn't well thought
out at all in fact you end portal 2
going I don't know what they're gonna do
if they make a third one it's like The
Dark Knight of puzzle games I don't have
a conventional rating system for games
yet I should work on that I know but no
matter what even though I wish portal 2
was longer I will say portal 2 is
awesome tacular and the ending of the
single-player campaign though holy [ __ ]
I'm not going to give you any spoilers
or anything like that but the ending to
the single-player campaign is like the
most epic moment ever this is the kind
of stuff that movies should do but
they're not going to do because they're
not as cool as portal 2 for some reason
the portal games are those games that
you can actually watch your friends play
in you're entertained I hate watching my
friends play RPGs I hate watching my
friends play most games portal 2 though
you're like I want to see how they get
through this puzzle you want to see the
look on their faces when GLaDOS or
whoever gives them verbal abuse it's
good stuff really rare that a game can
entertain the watchers as well as the
players the portal 2 pulls that off but
just being hilarious and entertaining so
play it laugh download the droid app for
the voices great stuff and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you